the world got to see james corden as a
fat [ __ ]
he was also in the movie cats but
no one saw that um and the reviews
are shocking i saw one that said this is
the worst thing to happen to cats
since dogs right
but dame judi dench defended the film
saying it was the role she was born to
play
because she i can't do this next joke
[Applause]
because she loves nothing better than
plonking herself down on the carpet
lifting her leg and licking her
[Applause]
verbal verbal she's old school
um
israel is reporting that they vaccinated
half of their population
and i'm going to guess it's the jewish
half
one of my friends has gotten so many
dui's
that he had to go to jail for a year now
his only concern was getting
raped so he didn't take a shower for the
entire year
because he was so busy getting raped
all right when i was at school a mate of
mine got caught wanking in the showers
nothing well it ruined the school trip
to auschwitz
it's a complicated country people get
angry they don't everybody hates gay
people
i never understood anger towards gay
people because a person being gay
doesn't affect your life so it's weird
to me that people just like
they're in their homes going oh people
are gay
damn it
what do you care i can understand hating
gay people if say like you're mowing
your lawn and
two guys are blowing each other right on
the grass oh i gotta cut around you
[ __ ] every sunday i'm sick of this
[ __ ]
or say you're eating your breakfast in
the morning and you're about to put your
spoon in the cereal bowl and two guys
touch dicks right in front of hey come
on
[Applause]
i gotta get to work i don't have time to
dodge your dicks with my spoon
[ __ ] homos get out of my kitchen
dear points of view watching queen eye
for the straight guy
made me think that if i made gay friends
they'd give me fashion tips
actually they [ __ ] me
sorry i know that's probably not funny
for any mildly autistic people in the
audience
then again nothing is
[Applause]
i i did i got into an argument with
[ __ ] like that it was a
defending child pornography that's why
maybe
but it was it was a censorship argument
and they always bring it to the
most awful whatever it's like when you
have a pro-drug
argument and then oh you think all drugs
should be legal you think
children should have heroin i go i'm not
a parent that's a parent's decision i
guess
that's not my point but they always take
it and it was a censorship
argument where they're oh if we had no
censorship do you think we should have
child pornography on network television
and go
no one would sponsor it this is a
[ __ ] moot point
it's a free market system yeah his
sponsors drive this show and then
what's gonna [ __ ] tide isn't gonna be
doing oh chopping no one's gonna watch
i'd look for a second i would
i watch i go on rotten.com i see [ __ ]
murder people's heads
cut off my [ __ ] serbian war crime
torture
[ __ ]
i ain't jacking off dude
isn't that the problem why is child
pornography the guy with the kid in the
camera
definitely a problem
why is it why is child pornography the
only crime it's illegal to see
caught on tape every other crime caught
on tape hit television
show photography what if you watch
child pornography because you find it
hilarious
then should it not be a protective
protected freedom of speech it's an art
form then if you just
can't believe that what if i jack off
to cops
drive through the hay field come on
drive through the hay field
you can lose that pig come on drive
through the field
it's illegal i'll jack it up too
some gold-plated chains would make a
nice retirement gift
for a very very good slave
are you serious well this was written
are you serious written here
did you just write that i didn't write
it did you say that
no i read it yes you read that
[Music]
and since i have this new sunny
disposition
my life's really turned around i've got
more friends i tolerate others i'm now
godfather the three children and that's
[ __ ]
because these people know me and they
still
[ __ ] ask they still come up and go
jim will you be the child's godfather
and i'm like
yes and then i stand there in church
with the priests and the parents and the
priest is holding the baby and the
priest turns to me and goes jim
will you spiritually guide this child
throughout its life
sure
because i have no problems lying in
church
what difference does it make now there
are two reasons why babies are
christened
right there's the real reason which is
the church are trying to recruit people
who can't talk
then there's a second reason the bible's
reasons god's reason this is why
god wants you to christen your child
because if you don't christen your child
and it dies in infancy it doesn't get
into heaven
so if you are religious your god sounds
like a super guy
but if he lets one dead baby into heaven
then he has to let all the dead babies
into heaven
and before you know it heaven's just
filled with [ __ ] dead babies
[Applause]
won't be able to move for dead babies
let's not act like these babies didn't
know what they did